the events in Parliament on Wednesday
night were to say the least
truly shocking the use of language on
both sides was finding but in particular
Boris Johnson's language marked a new
low in the Commons his dismissal of
homely legitimate concerns about the
safety of women MPs with the word humbug
was outrageous and to say that the best
way of honoring the murdered MP Joe Cox
is to deliver brexit was insulting to
her memory the question is was this just
a prime minister out of his debts after
a terrible week in which he was
humiliated by the Supreme Court or was
it a calculated act of naked populism an
attempt to turn the people against
Parliament against their elected
representatives against our democratic
system I suspect it's the latter let's
just remember a few things I'm surprised
you find it truly shocking and
frightening I mean there's been some
pretty robust behavior down the years in
there Michael Heseltine grabbing hold of
the mace the way Thatcher another
commitment away Thatcher and Kennet used
to go at each other as well and on the
prime minister's defense he didn't bring
Joe Cox into the conversation the Labour
Party chose to bring Joe Cox into the
conversation to which the Prime Minister
responded but so just to challenge you
on those parts overall to me that shows
why Boris Johnson was right to
perot-gore suspend Parliament because
what was achieved yesterday and what
he's going to be that is all that is now
going to happen he was absolutely right
to clone try and close down Parliament
and if they feel it's so keenly great
why did they have a long summer recess
why didn't they get all this nonsense
going on during the week after week
after week that they all had off in the
summer so that's the reality of how I
see it well obviously I disagree but I'm
and iris I'm interested in in in
particularly what happened last night I
think I mean if you look at a series of
decisions by the Prime Minister
I suspect advice by Dominic coming
someone you've got first of all he's
they made a mistake on they thought if
they called it if they called an
election labour would support them and
they got it wrong
secondly they
a lot of Tory MPs who in other other
occasions would support them and they
got it wrong and certainly rogue in
Parliament they've got one now is it all
part of a pattern is it all did for
something some other reason is this
actually gonna be you go to the people
on a populist empty Parliament platform
well to support that but not it it just
occurs to me course some people might
not have seen some of the events so
here's just a little bit of the Prime
Minister in action on Wednesday night
the capitulation act or the surrender
whatever you want to put it it does it
does I'm sorry but it it greatly
enfeebles it greatly in fievel's its
government's ability to negotiate but
what I will say is that the best way to
honor the memory of Joe Cox and indeed
the best way to bring this country
together would be I think to get brexit
done and I absolutely do and I think
that it is the continuing inability of
this Parliament to get brexit done that
is causing the anxiety and the ill
feeling that is now rampant in our
country and it has to be said that there
was language such as that on all sides
cowards cheats frauds whatever else it
might have been I upgrade I've seen it
all before it's not particular it's not
particularly how it's done but it
doesn't surprise I mean this Prime
Minister is a rabble rouser that's what
he does I mean well but that's what he
does if you go back over history you
don't find many mobile browsers as Prime
Minister I mean go back to what go back
to the forties we're not even was very
rude about the Tories his prime minister
told him to tone it down yeah well we
can have we can have a discussion about
whether one person or another person is
more rhetorical another but I think
there's something deeper going going on
here and that's to do with a language of
politics and them and what politicians
think are important it's probably worth
looking at what made people so or why
people were so angry let's have a look
at paula sheriff MP because that's what
really touched things off
like I have to say mr. speaker I've
never heard such humbug in all my life
yeah and that was in a way emphasized by
I have to bring in my regular soul
sister here the Labour MP just just full
of we don't look alike which she tweeted
today that she'd had an anonymous letter
saying that if dunk Downing Street might
think we're all humbugs about his word
but they're literally being used in
death threats against her she said now I
can understand why people are saying
what they're saying I'm a bit uneasy now
about the way that everything that the
escalation of language and so on because
this and I want to be clear I don't want
to dismiss anything that anybody has
said but let's remember Stephen Tim's
law before bricks long before all of
this Stephen James 2010 was almost
murdered
I mean summer Gleeson Abram the Labour
MP in the East End
almost murdered by an Islamist extremist
and all of this language has been going
on from for a long time you know when I
24 became president of me anyways the
morning after I got elected I had the
death threat
I had a cartoon with me hanging when I
did see Ari we had a meet somebody fired
an air Grande through my window came in
the found a hole the next morning the it
this is not just because and what's
happening now there a coarsening of
politics which is long term I think we
need to think about why that what's
driving that I think that a lot of this
language was initiated in the tabloid
press
I remember we saw that we did because we
had front-page headlines crushed the
saboteurs we had the judiciary being and
all the MPs remain and peace being
enemies of the people
words like collaborationist traitor
betrayal my brothers using words like
surrender capitulation as if the people
who are standing in the way of the
Blessed will of the people as defined by
the seventeen point four million votes
in 2016 should be hung drawn and
quartered tarred and feathered and I
think that is highly reprehensible
language to use and I hope that today in
the comments were recording this on
Thursday there will be some sort of deal
on both sides all sides that this sort
of thing is utterly dialed down it
serves from no purpose I just want to
say one thing about the Joe Cox remark I
also think it was particularly tasteless
to for those who are grieving a mother
an MP and a friend to say that the best
way to honor her memory is to deliver
the thing that she and her family
campaigned against which is brazen I
know he did and I think I think it was a
non very tasteless way of referring to
the memory of a murdered MP murdered by
somebody who said Britain first who is
obviously of the far-right tendency
which you could argue is being whipped
up by this sort of language all your
brother's just trying to say get free
the country of this this is really I
think what he said was please let's all
come down get this done so we could move
on but I'm afraid that was not the
teacher Michele we've we've gone so far
that we're missing one simple premise
now which is the word professionalism we
seem to have forgotten that Parliament
and politicians this is a professional
work environment and when I watched
Parliament last night I had to turn it
off I was embarrassed and first of all I
turned the volume down because it was
screeching name-calling you've gone
through all of the courts you've gone
through all this stuff to to get
yourself reconvened and that is what you
do when you've got
your your we convention we've lost sight
the fact that you're professionals and
I'd like people to act like that and the
language is it is it's not scary
necessarily but it's deeply unnecessary
deeply unprofessional
and I find it fascinating that people
are upset by the use of the word
surrender but excuse me if you need to
bleep me out what they'll be upset at
the word surrender but being deeply
comfortable with the word has been used
in a professional environment
grexit being used in a professional
environment and I just don't think that
is acceptable all the language needs to
calm down become professional and do the
jobs that we're paying you to do in the
manner of who do you think is gonna gain
from what's happening well I actually
think that there'll be many breaks or
tears who watch this and they're very
much in support of borås and what he's
doing and how he's doing it and I do
believe that you're heading into the
territory of an election which will be
people against Parliament whether you
call up poeple ISM or whatever label you
want to apply to that I think that it is
playing into those people I think that
they are comforted by the actions that
they see Boris taking at the moment I I
groove Michel but Greg you've raised a
really important point and I'd like to
drag it away from yesterday and today a
bit because and I don't think this is
just a thing of today I mean what
Michelle said it's taken me back to when
I was president of the NUS is the
housing time for it I'm afraid I just
want to say very quickly last year I
wrote a pamphlet for politics change a
think tank called the age of incivility
and we went back over 20 years this has
been growing and growing and reason we
think it's happening is because the
politicians would rather spend the time
denigrating each other's character than
wrestling with the actual issues of
substance and that's what the heart of
this is about right are you about
telling the people who your opponent is
a bad guy are you actually trying to
answer the question that the people have
posed